yeah well I've got an idea it's your
idea I want you to say good morning John
and then I'll be like good morning okay
that's uh we've had that idea before I
know it's still funny though good
morning John
good morning now we're together
let's go on the dance floor and I don't
know how to reach a total sexuality
don't my defining cream chant they some
skinny jeans and cutting it into the
only way to go but now it seems that
Oxfam employees and not the ones who
know just how it works
give me a minute while I fiddle with my
hair if you keep telling me that
it looks fine but I'm the one who cares
about a good impression being made
like get late don't tell me how the game
is played don't
how the game is played in case you tells
me her favorite band is my thing for and
and how do I know which drink she'd want
me to buy me what do I look her in the
eye when did the indie music scene
become so over fuss so she'll in Natick
OC beats knocked me to the ground if I'm
already falling in
make things worse you know I always
liked all the sage this evening filling
me with rage I only wish I had some sage
advice to give to me the indie handbook
vol 3 with Michel girls you fancy room
by getting rid their boyfriends placed
your party loving mates with organ music
boyfriends who like listening to Sonic
you know endless kathira loop remember
no amount of faking make your indie band
groundbreaking oh don't think you're
special or much less of a disgrace
just because you got yourself a lady who
plays bass don't bother finding somebody
play
you back in working order huh got a
different sound you're all part of the
underground you haven't been together
long to try so I got talking to
Oh
guys oh I could cry out only the reason
why
I love you
they love it
anyway
off of them
again I wouldn't do that for $1,000
punishment
yeah that's not a funny punishment
punishment will make you two the frog
hopper not be all over the place I
literally wouldn't do that for $1,000 I
might not do it for $10,000 I don't want
to do that at all